again one of the most difficult
broadcasts
probably in the history of the new york
mets as over the last
little bit less than 24 hours now we
have all tried to process
the loss of the franchise tom seaver who
passed away last night a day for
reflection mourning and sorrow to be
sure but also celebrating the life and
career of one of the all-time greats
tom stephen and i think the mets of also
wayne devised one of the
coolest tributes they possibly could
have come up with
every member of the new york mets is
taking some dirt
and putting it on their right knee
symbolic of
how tom's uniform looked three and two
against the mets
and a fly ball out to center mariznick
back a couple of strides
and he reels it in for the first down
and he smashes one to right but
conforto's right there to pick it off
and the throwback to first base and
boyd's able to
recover and get back and a ground ball
hits slowly charging rosario
and he throws out frazier so the yankees
have the bases loaded
with one man out for tyler wade
that one is lined in the center field it
is a base hit
or shella scores
and gardner holds it third so wade picks
up a single
and the yankees have a one nothing lead
so base is loaded
one out one and here is dj three 3-2
fly ball right field conforto
makes the catch tagging is gardner he's
going to score it's a sac fly for lemayo
and the yankees
have a two-nothing lead runners first
and third two out here's boyd wade goes
from first 3-2
and hammered a base hit to left field
that's going to go to the corner
higashioka scores easily wade is
rounding
third and he is going to score as well
it's a two-run double for boyd and it's
four
nothing yankees and he walked him
that loads the bases again for the
yankees 42 pitches in the second inning
and unable to
get out of it an inning in two thirds
for gazellman he'll exit chase and
shreve will come on
last of the second yankees four minutes
nothing todd frazier leads off pitch
get in the air to right field fairly
deep slicing towards the corner frazier
over it might go
and it's gone a home run todd frazier
tucked that one about 10 feet to the
left of the foul pole
in the right field corner for frazier
his third home run of the year
and the mints are on the board the
yankees lead is cut to 4-1
infield back yankees with a three-run
lead alonso trying to get that runner in
from third with one out
[Applause]
and he chases the pitch out of the zone
and gets the strikeout
as alonso he's a runner at third base
with one out now it's two outs two outs
runner on third
mariznick drives one deep left field
back goes garner it's over his head and
off the base of the wall
frazier is in and marissa pulls into
second base with an rbi
double a bolt off the bat of jake
perisic to get the mets closer it's now
four to two
two outs mariznick at second rosario's
the batter it's a four to two yankee
lead it's the fourth inning
rosario hits it hard right side past
lemay you into right field
mariznick rounds third he'll score
easily and another two out rbi for the
mets
here in the fourth inning ahmed rosario
makes it a one-run
game as the yankees lead has been cut to
four to three
runner at second rosario runner at first
torino's
jeff mcneil has hit the ball hard twice
today neal lines one into center field
for a base hit and that'll tie up the
game
rosario scores torino's to third jeff
mcneal with an rbi
single and the mitts have come from four
runs down to draw even
it's four to four in the fourth
[Applause]
beautiful play by archello off balance
throw when he gets frazier
he took an extra base hit away from it's
not only catching this ball is to throw
against your body to put the perfect arc
on this throw and just a perfect
strike to ford what a tremendous play he
got the ground ball his momentum took
him away in foul territory
and he still threw on carport is on and
the yankees have two on and two out
for geo urchella big spot here on the
seven tie game castro deals
hit sharply and through for base hit
hicks rounds third he's coming home
here's the throw and he is safe moving
to third
is ford he's in there a big big hit for
urchella
as the yankees take a 5-4 lead so first
and third and here is gardner the 2-1
and it's a fair ball down the
right-field lineup kicks off the gate
scoring his fourth or shella will stop
at third it's an rbi double for gardner
and the yankees lead 6-4 but he has a
361 on base percentage which is the 18th
highest
and there's a base hit through the left
side that'll score lemay who voigt stops
at second a big rbi single
for aaron hicks and it's seven four
yankees so the tying runs are aboard
here
and ahmed rosario is going to be the
battery here
rosario toward the right side hole
estrada can't get it base hit
in the score comes frazier smith will
score as well
maurizio to third it's 7-6
ahmed rosario with his third hit of the
day drives in a pair
geraldis chapman taking the mound while
appealing his three-game suspension that
was imposed after his
dust up with the tampa bay rays the
other night
so now basically tied for the mets a
one-strike count to davis
takes off for third swinging to miss
throw to third
oh they got him what was hamilton
thinking going to third there
and higashiyoka got him with a perfect
throw
jd hits it out to center field hicks
giving ground to the warning
davis comes the game dave is dead
central against all this jump after the
mets get even
it's 7-7 in the night so smith is the
free runner at second
alonzo the batter 7-7 bottom of the 10th
that's driven deep down the left-field
line toward the stage
[Applause]
in the bottom of the tent and the mets
yank it out
9-7 and he ends a long day of baseball
with a very satisfying win
on a day that we honor the memory of top
seaver